well well
welcome back maleficent fans disney's
live actions have been taking over the
film industry in full force
including one of their biggest hits
maleficent but if you've ever watched
angelina jolie's maleficent
you know that disney strayed far away
from the plot of the original sleeping
beauty
in this video we'll be taking a look at
just how different the two movies are by
delving behind the scenes of both
which movie really is the better story
and did disney make a mistake with their
live action or was it the change
sleeping beauty needed all along
did you hear that my pen
let's start off with the most basic
difference in the making of the two
films
they're actors of course disney's remake
had hollywood sweetheart angelina jolie
take on the role of maleficent
in the films in sleeping beauty actress
eleanor oddly was cast for the role but
she was no stranger to the disney world
she also voiced lady tremaine in
cinderella making the movie a live
action
of course saved the work of having to
animate angelina jolie but the
production put in the time making her
perfect in another way
she didn't just grow out those sharp
cheekbones overnight angelina spent
hours in hair and makeup while the
artist perfected her look for the film
oddly also spent some time physically
transforming for the role
she had to act out the scenes in costume
in order to help animators portray her
real-life movements
overall their costumes horns and
intimidating looks are pretty similar
next up the one and only princess aurora
of course
the elegant l fanning took on the role
of the cursed princess in the live
action and brought to life a modern
version of let's face it the pretty
bland original version
but there was nothing bland about the
voice behind the animated sleeping
beauty
mary costa took on that role back in the
1950s but another actress
helene stanley was actually the face
behind sleeping beauty
she was the live-action model for the
animation of aurora while helane was
dressed in a real-life costume of what
came across in the animation
elle fanning's version of aurora
included much more variety in her
wardrobe
the similarities between their
appearances stop at their blonde hair
and kind face
now here's what the real big differences
start in the production of the two films
did you ever watch sleeping beauty and
wonder why
exactly maleficent was so mad at the
royals that she would put an evil curse
on their innocent daughter
besides not being invited to the
ceremony there was never really any
reason behind it
i really felt quite distressed and not
receiving an
invitation but in maleficent that all
gets answered
maleficent wasn't exactly evil in the
live action she is only seeking revenge
on aurora's father king stefan
after saving his life he betrays her by
seducing her drugging her and then
cutting off her wings
that is why she became the evil queen of
the moors with a thirst for revenge
the maleficent script definitely gave
the character a more in-depth
personality
and weirdly had a sympathizing with her
despite her evil ways
another fun fact angelina's daughter
actually crashed a brainstorming session
where she helped the screenwriters come
up with an important storyline in a
sequel involving the dark fae
one of the most iconic scenes of the
original movie has to be when maleficent
transforms into a literal fire-breathing
dragon in the final battle against
prince philip
however in the film maleficent that
never happens instead in the live action
maleficent turns her familiar divole
into a dragon instead
another plot twist at the end of those
battles is that in sleeping beauty
maleficent meets her demise
but in maleficent it's king stefan they
take down the closest maleficent ever
comes to transforming into a dragon is
in maleficent mistress of evil when
aurora's tears resurrect her from the
ashes as a phoenix
speaking of maleficent's familiar there
are huge differences between him and the
two worlds
in sleeping beauty he's the classic evil
sidekick sitting on her shoulder and
doing her dirty work he's also strictly
a crow
while in maleficent he's all those
things we mentioned above let's just say
he's more of a character
not only does he get a name dival but
maleficent has the power to transform
him into a human when needed
his human version is played by sam riley
and while he might have human features
the filmmaker still made sure he kept
his dark crow vibes
we can't forget his rendezvous as a
dragon as well
while the actors and storyline are
definitely very important when making
sure you produce an amazing movie
there's something else that needs to be
perfect to bring
everything to life the set and scene
production considering one movie was
animated and the other a live action
their approach to get that perfection
was of course very different
in the case of sleeping beauty disney
and walt himself hired an artist that
would illustrate the scenes before any
animating happened in fact walt was very
adamant that sleeping beauty's
illustrations had to translate perfectly
after he believed some of his past
movies illustrations never got
translated on screen properly
if you take a look at behind the scenes
filming of maleficent most of the time
the actors are working on a set that
consists of multiple green screens
vfx and cgi were the true winners of the
film if it wasn't for them
the film would not have been able to be
brought to life the way it was
like any good fairy tale movie the day
is saved by true love's kiss in both
films
but even that part of the story is
altered when it comes to maleficent
in sleeping beauty it's prince philip
who swoops in kisses her and breaks the
dreadful sleeping curse
however in maleficent it's maleficent
herself that breaks the curse because of
her love for aurora
instead of waiting for the day where she
would finally get her revenge like in
sleeping beauty
in the live action maleficent grew fond
of aurora referring to herself as her
godmother and even trying to secretly
find a way to stop aurora's impending
doom
overall though both true love's kiss
scenes were filmed and set pretty
similarly
like we mentioned before king stefan is
the reason why maleficent is seeking
revenge in the first place
however not only did he drug and rip off
her wings but he also ended up lying his
way into royalty and stealing the throne
that's right unlike king stefan's
nobility in sleeping beauty he started
off as an evil peasant and orphan who
betrayed many
the differences in their physical
appearances are definitely worth noting
as well
while maleficent's love is what breaks
the curse in the live action it doesn't
mean prince philip wasn't important in
the maleficent films
in sleeping beauty prince philip is your
classic disney prince he's betrothed to
aurora the moment she is born and
happens to spontaneously fall in love
with her at first sight
he's even got the traditional prince
look royal steed and all
while in maleficent he still has royalty
vibes with his sandy hair and horse
their love story is completely different
they are taken with each other during
their first meeting but they go through
more of a courting process and don't
even get engaged until the sequel
what would the story of princess aurora
be without her fairy godmothers
probably not as entertaining let's be
real while in both sleeping beauty and
maleficent their purpose is the same
raise and protect aurora their names and
appearances are slightly different
to start in sleeping beauty the
protectors go by the names flora fauna
and meriwether
in maleficent they're called thistle wit
flittle and not grass
the original film also made sure that
the fairies were presented as super
fantastical with glitter big dresses and
magic wands
but in maleficent they were more one
with nature they all still had their own
color but were more understated fairies
they were also part of maleficent's very
very complicated history
shout out to actresses juno temple
imelda staunton and leslie manville for
bringing the live-action versions to
life
let's be real angelina definitely
brought a whole new level of awesome to
maleficent with her impeccable acting
skills and piercing eyes
there's no comparing but she didn't
bring the awesomeness to maleficent
alone the filmmakers took an old disney
character and made her into an icon
one way they did this was through her
powers in sleeping beauty in addition to
her evil powers
she can transport using a type of spin
magic we gotta admit
it looked pretty cool for a 1950s film
but in maleficent she had wings which
meant she could fly
and oh can she fly in fact her getting
her wings cut off is what gets the
entire plot of the franchise going
it's also pretty interesting to get a
look behind the scenes of how they made
these powers come to life in each film
there's no doubt that tons of hours and
hard work went into the making of these
films despite their differences
it's also changed the way we watch these
films now knowing just what went into
them behind the scenes
were any of these behind the scenes
changes shocking to you let us know if
you prefer maleficent or sleeping beauty
in the comments section below
don't forget to give this a thumbs up
and hit that subscribe button for more
of these fairy tale videos
catch you in another kingdom
you